[Music]
last Friday night daredevil Nik Wallenda
successfully walked across Niagara Falls
on a wire it was just stunning the
footage is amazing the photographs just
a stunning achievement it looks so
impressive well we think there might be
someone trying to top that tonight we
have a tightrope walker with us this
evening
attempting a far more dangerous stunt so
renowned daredevil Anton Sinclair and
he's going to attempt to walk across the
Santa Monica Bay located right behind me
in this real window and he's going to
walk across the entire Santa Monica Bay
let's see if he's there yet I think
there he is
[Applause]
it was amazing amazing we didn't see all
wind picking up the wind picking up
right now let's hope he survives the
wind very windy out here man confirming
what I just said well yeah like the same
wind is picking up but no he seems to
benefit Oh No there's a flock of
seagulls I hope that's not problem
[Applause]
[Music]
the Bears continuing on nothing will
suffice